my name welcome back to Dawson barrows
Dawson I knew you were behind this hey
hey oh I gotta find dodo what stopped
running at me
holy [ __ ] you're beautiful ah it looks
like a Japanese psycho
die [ __ ] I'll tell you doing standing
at the wall I'm more interesting in oh
no oh no a talk oh no wait
back off I have a baton that's how I
roll [ __ ] that's how I'll get all the
ladies I just bite tongue and they're
like oh come here let me show you man he
looks like a barber Hey yes oh baby
sweet baby inventory is full no I have a
shotgun and you better listen
oh he shot himself that's what happened
so that's how you become a barber
I love Lamar very especially a barber
pie all right rhubarb's or something I
don't know what it's called in English
all right so I'm looking for something
like it Oh matter - inventories full
that's not good I guess I should use my
serene or something all right
[ __ ] don't look kids you don't look
either I don't know how old you are you
could be our waiter
you can't look he's dead and I'd give me
that all right I have a lighter now
that's good
all right that's a shame you can't carry
more than but I guess it makes sense all
right
anyone else wanna [ __ ] with me you [ __ ]
with the missus shotty
mr. Chou lives in a bad mood he's on his
period even though he's a man
and that's what we call it where I'm
from at least okay wait I thought I were
something here if I remember correctly
yes baby nine bucks shell sub I don't
know what they're called oh never mind
all right
nice going here what is this sand I love
San that's also convenient
Oh Nipplegate
Oh everywhere all right BAM just say I'm
Oprah it's gonna be pest Wow
Oh No Oh No reload reload reload nipple
guys we've been through this before
nipple guys left nipple right now [ __ ]
quadruped on their phone
Oh present a pulse there we go all right
barrel Dawson I will find you'd mr.
Dawson if it's the last thing I'll do
I'll find him and I'll make him into a
rhubarb pie all right so let's light the
oil and run the [ __ ] out of here I'm not
sure if I should wait here we go
all right no how do i oh I just do like
this Equipe used yes should i Exeter I
get the feelings kind of blow I don't
know if I should exit there stay well
that did [ __ ] nothing less fantastic
how am I supposed to but the lighter it
what what do I supposed to do something
there no it can't be passed by no BAM
why did I it was supposed to be explode
I don't know what I did maybe this door
is open now oh it is
oh whatever let's did not complain I
have the silver case for let's continue
see you later blue box all right in the
nipple guys wanna [ __ ] with me
I didn't think so can I do it with this
no I can't do it have been so I think
alright I think the door is this one
mr. darshan barrel is use the key let's
go in here
new adventures I don't like this free
addicts that's not good
seemed like the game crashed alright
we're back apparently if you launch the
game with the launcher instead of using
it through Steam that will fix that
problem in case someone else bump into
that I can't go there but Tom hey I can
splash OH
wouldn't it be awesome to make that
sound if you hit water I'm the same
alright oh damn girl
all I wanted to know what did you what
that's a good question
Matt's here again god damn I just want
to stop people I want that stop Oh what
girl
oh no oh no it's another boss fight what
should I do
yeah barbaric oh no god damn it is Jesus
who got ass look at that alright come at
me bro
all right Bam Bam Bam Bam it does
nothing god damn it what should I do
Jesus tell me whatever you are god damn
it I am I am I am
Maggie's but maybe [ __ ] [ __ ] this is not
good
no it's good though bring it [ __ ]
you're so slow you're slower than my
mouth today I almost said something
weird I always say something rate it at
a tete-a-tete change my nipples i all of
them all that ass let me smack that
smack your ass smack that ass smack that
ass
oh no what should i do what should i do
what should i do oh okay I get it
oh no oh no oh no please wait there
please ah that's way tight all right
oh wait we got a lot of time all right
let's drag oh man Oh in here yeah bad I
guess
terrifying nah I don't want to see his
head all right
Jesus give me strength to do this spin
the wheel penny I'm spinning I'm
spinning Oh
got a sound of a bee sting come on we
can do this brush I know we can do it
all right no no I hate the bike oh wait
it's okay it's okay okay thank you
stop stalling his head up spoon the
wheel I'm spreading Brenda Rhett softcup
retired egg ah that ice gets going there
spin the well pity a spread egg shut up
I can do it stop telling me Otto Gahr
spin the wheel spin the mail spin the
wheel spin the wheel spin stop you're
creeping the hell out of me spend the
wealth payday spend the well paying a
grand well I was reading like about
spinning this thing's been spinning
been expanding many many things fame
fame fame you think huh
spinning spinning spinning me yes a
touch oh no yes
tasted like a be a us four six seven
eight nine core drop an apple oh nice
Venice Venice spinning spinning spinning
my dad are you mad you're mad brah umad
about my spinning skills
alright I'd spin over here at spin
everywhere spinning the way all my all
my spinning skills by coming three years
I didn't even know anymore
I'm spinning I'm spinning and spinning
spinning I did it eat it yes that's what
I'm talking about
Beatrice I love [ __ ] this is not a
beast uh but I love it oh no you're not
gonna get to me sir I love your face but
I can't love your tongue too no no not
today sir not today
this is not today what I'm gonna know
this is my thing
this is my thing it's what I go this is
my life oh no no place name pizza yes
die [ __ ] die oh I love your tongue
that's what you get for killing Jesus
I'm going to need some big to cut that
key which key what's the key
I never saw the key I sit in his face
and it's penis perhaps Jesus ready to
put the cage ASIS down man all right
let's go here he locked the door all
right I'll use my chopping knife
chopping top top
where is the key what oh this changed
all right I guess we'll just keep going
keep on trolling I have a baton [ __ ]
I have a baton all right fine I'll go in
here I don't even care
yes [ __ ] I can't forget the serene
I'm full all right let's use this down
so happy
I always oh I can't use that I I can
only like oh you rumors mom be gentle
with me Reubens mom seriously scare me
punch you a puncher face I know it hurts
but I have to do it humans mom oh oh
come on don't sneak up on me rooms mom
don't sneak up behind me I don't like it
there you go I punch you I punch you for
sneaking up on me that bluey blue I love
you I missed you buddy
all right let's cut up this penis I
don't even know anymore I guess this is
the penis he's cutting off yeah
definitely the game so the key is the
penis I wonder how biggest ding dong is
the rustic key we got it like a fuss Oh
lovely nice hole you got that you can
now I changed your sex in just a few
seconds that's what you get
use the key money come on all right so
it's not that door which door is it then
maybe I should put it in my hand all
right
so it's in here
this is where I came from oh it's
probably this door yeah there we go
let's say first actually all right I
scared he yeah yeah
Hey another one lovely I love tape
recorder baby when their lights go out
bayaud I was just recording who does
that
I hate Cora - bring it don't bring it
I'm kidding
hey potato head and no more no more
anyone oh no oh no oh okay oh no that's
okay we're in a bagina happens all the
time all right
lovely what do you think I think you
like this that's a common question when
I mean someone's Madonna you don't know
anything that's not every day though if
you just could understand now I move on
to this what the hell oh no this is not
my typical the diner I think I just want
you to die just die that happened before
a couple times and just hit it all right
I don't like this Oh what the hell ah -
stop tickling I don't like it which way
which way which way stop taking me
sucking me his tickles tickles like
crazy take it's like crazy because I
crazy goddamn it
stop tickling me you sons of [ __ ]
come on we're almost there so close so
close this is gonna be a tough one
yep yes police Ben what did you do
policeman oh no oh this is how it
started yeah policeman what are you
doing that British Ben yes he's crazy I
know him taking out a couple beers some
time there was some hardcore tickling
Hey probablemente probably nothing am I
going insane probably meant a tune I
love the voice I play it again I need to
get some help or at least find my way
back home I think you're right buddy all
right I wonder who that sick doctor is
he must have done something to me
probably I agree all right I'm wearing
it oh we need find a gas man chapter 3
all right I'm gonna hit Bruce like a
free person George just kind of come
Bruce Lee I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
right
let's just stretch my way
[Music]
[Applause]